does it feel like 40 years
uh it it certainly doesn't seem like 40
years you know where does the time goes
zoom i always knew someday you'd come
walking back through my door
do you and harrison talk do you stay in
contact we talk every now and then i
talked to him a couple weeks ago
because you know there are certain
events taking place that that sort of
you know uh are interesting for us to
talk about
so does that mean karen's coming back
for indiana jones
5 the movie just started production in
england with 78 year old harrison
reprising his role
i'm excited to play the character again
i love making those films they're great
entertainment yeah that in spite of what
he told us
almost 40 years ago how would you feel
about indiana jones being there forever
he won't be he's getting too old
it was hard a hard physical job
it's just uh one more useless experience
is there a moment on set that's the most
vivid for you that you remember so well
i certainly loved and always loved it to
see it in the bar
i learned to hate you in the last 10
years
i never meant to hurt you they gave me
that scene to audition with
and um i fell in love with the character
just right off the bat
have i ever punched anyone in the face
in my life
absolutely not i suppose there could be
a circumstance
that would bring that out in me but i
haven't encountered it as yet
now in celebration of indy's 40th
anniversary all four films of the
adventure
franchise are being re-released in a
deluxe 4k
ultra hd set for the first time and
streaming on paramount plus
so karen gets to relive iconic moments
like this
what was in the shot glasses i could
tell you we were
you know doing shots but it was colored
water
what can i say
[Music]
for a number of years like every time i
would go into a bar with friends or
whatever
like you know within moments i'd have a
shot glass that sort of whacked down on
the bar right in front of me and
somebody pouring me a shot of whiskey so
it followed me for a long time that that
scene
you